hey everybody what's going on it's bobby
and i'm back at the geek culture studios
with a friend of mine over here orion uh
reason being we're here to talk about
backpacks now i'm a person that carries
backpacks pretty much every day of my
life in singapore i take a variety of
different transport you know on a
motorcycle bus you can public transport
like trains even a car sometimes but i'm
going to the gym i carry camera
equipment i carry a variety of different
things and i have a lot of different
bags for that reason
but i would love to have a backpack that
does all of it without needing to change
so 227design.com reached out to me they
said bobby we actually have a backpack
we would like you to try
give us your honest feedback on it and i
said well what's the difference between
all the other backpacks that i have and
they said well this is modular so you
can make it whatever you want it to be
so i tried this backpack over the past
couple weeks
by the way we're not paid or sponsored
for this review mind you okay and i'm
really impressed with the engineering
the tech and just how well this performs
and i thought i'd share with you guys in
case you're looking for a backpack like
myself that can do pretty much
everything
let's talk about the orion backpack from
227design.com
by the way if you notice on the back of
these bags here this leather hand grip
on the black and also here on the
heather one wouldn't it be cool if you
could actually customize this with your
initials well
227design.com and geekculture are going
to allow you to do this click on the
link below it'll take you to their site
and then you can customize it put your
initials in there and this will be a
complimentary uh gift courtesy of
227design.com
[Music]
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
the p-leather 2.0 is isn't your cup of
tea then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.co
so before we get into things i do want
to let you know a little bit about this
backpack in terms of the design and the
modularity now the style packs as they
call them i have them all here we'll put
them on the backpack as we go through
this review so 227design.com is actually
partnered with vidlock on this to use
these locking mechanisms all throughout
this backpack on the outside the side
and inside the bag to attach these style
packs to it so they lock into place
they're secure
but allows you to carry a lot of weight
if you need to without worry of these
style packs popping off because they do
not as a matter of fact you'll see in
just a minute
how well they lock on it's kind of a
pain to take off anyway let's look at
the design first and foremost this is
this weather resistant sort of ballistic
nylon material to it it's really robust
it's got a nice hardened shape to it as
you can tell this backpack stands
straight up don't need to touch it
because it's designed to be this way so
if you put a lot of things in this bag
it still stands up which is nice keeps
it uh you know you don't want a bag that
flops on the ground and gets dirty and
all those germs and all that stuff but
at the same time you want something that
has structure to it so if you're
carrying a lot of expensive items or
laptops tablets camera equipment
clothing for that matter you want easy
access to it you don't have to worry
about that at all which is a nice um
touch to that so moving to the back of
this we have this mesh material that is
really good for wicking because in our
hot humid climate like this in singapore
when you carry a backpack for long
periods of times especially when you're
walking outside it can be very sticky
this wicks that away quite well as a
matter of fact so i don't feel that
stickiness like i would on other let's
say leather backpacks or very you know
heavy-duty backpacks that are designed
for other climates so this is a really
nice feature the padding on the straps
to me this is one of the most important
things when you get a backpack because
you want something that's comfortable
there's nothing like loading up your
backpack with a lot of equipment or a
lot of clothes or a lot of things in
general and you just find that it
strains your shoulders you don't find
this at all with this orion backpack it
is really comfortable also yeah these
straps in the middle so if you want
extra security you can do that and you
can pop those off if you like to do that
as well also you have this sleeve here
so if you want let's say you want to you
know once we can travel again for us in
singapore we can go to the airport again
i cannot wait and let's say you have
your trolley bag with the long handle
you can slide that handle through here
and you're covered in that regard uh
moving to this back here we've got the
zipper pouch here so if you're worried
about people uh stealing your
credentials your off id tags whatever
the case may be or your credit cards
this is protected inside of here so
they've actually had this material so
people cannot scan your bag and uh you
know take your identification or
whatever your credit card numbers people
do that nowadays they do that exactly
not a victim yet i'm not a victim either
but i guess it's happened to some people
so you're covered in this backpack so
and then we actually have this magnetic
hidden pouch so you can actually store
stuff in there close it up it's magnet
good to go in that regard now speaking
of zippers for a second this is really
cool because we have two sets we have
one with rubber tips and one with
metallic tips now the reason that they
have done it this way
and i was told this is because you know
when we have a bag with a lot of
different zipper compartments to it
you're always kind of zipping and
unzipping oh that's not what i'm looking
for where's that where's this zipper
connected to
so they made it this way so you know the
rubber tips are for the main compartment
and the metallic tips are for where your
laptop and your tablet go
that's very cool so you don't have to
look you can actually just go by touch
and feel it let's look at the laptop
area here a 15 16 inch laptop it's
padded inside even a tablet as well
you've got a couple pockets in there
it's really well constructed again
weather resistant inside so you have to
worry about that
and then we go to the main compartment
this is where it gets interesting
because
you can completely unzip this
and
with these velcro tabs right here this
is opened completely so if you want to
use this as a staycation backpack for
example you want to put clothes or shoes
inside you have full access to this if
you want to put other equipment in there
you can do that as well you have various
different pouches
you know for your pens your credit cards
business cards cables whatever you want
to put in there you have that and it
also allows for that expandable storage
to this so this is a nice little uh
uh touch that they put into this also
you're going to notice this fit locks
here on each side and also hook here and
i'll show you why that's all there in
just a second though that is essentially
the backpack in a nutshell so this is
really well designed it feels fantastic
price point this is coming in i believe
it starts around 179 us and then goes on
up depending on how you can you
customize it this is a really good value
but now let's talk about the modularity
of the orion backpack so now let's talk
about the first style pack which is
probably the most common one that you're
going to find with the orion backpack
now this one is the one i use most of
the time because a it looks fantastic
and b there's a lot of different
compartments in this so as you can see
this is one backpack and these um knobs
right here are the locks that go into
the fidlock system so you see two on
each side and four here so you're not
always going to find a style pack with
all six on this because you don't
necessarily need it from what i
understand this locking system each lock
holds up to 15 kgs of weight so when you
put this all together this is not coming
off and you'll see how and why i mean
that in just a minute but let's look at
the design of this style pack first it's
really classy this is great for business
if you're going into an office setting
or if you want to go to something a
little bit more formal now you've got
this
calfskin leather trimming around this
the ykk zippers with the rubber tips on
it and you also have different
different uh compartments inside of
these pouch areas so you can put
business cards or whatever you want to
put in there
a lot of organization then also you have
these side pouches here so let's say you
want to put cables to your smartphone uh
extra batteries for whatever it may be
you can put those in
now
let's attach it to the bag and just show
you how this completely transforms it
once it's on it now the cool thing about
this is is that it's magnetic
in its design so you just kind of lay it
down
and locking into place
all secure as a matter of fact zacky
come over here a second try to pull this
off
you did it
okay okay try now
yeah come on arnold do it wow
it's really strong man okay
what we could just do is just kind of
like
you see how tight this is
now i might be able to pull off a lock
or two but it's not coming off you see
this that's how durable this is and i'm
i'm actually pulling on this not to say
this is ever going to happen on the
street but
that's the locking system in its place
it's not meant to be an anti-theft
system by the way no it's not anti-theft
but
it's durable and
it's comfy right it's comfy you like it
right
the back support is good right got like
a little bit of lumbar support it's
quite nice actually and to remove it
simple
just
[Music]
and to remove it you just got to sort of
lift up on each side so the lock is on
an angle like that so i said it's not
the easiest thing to get off there we go
see my friends it's it's all about
technique it's technique
there's technique to this there we go
so
as you can tell
modular but not the easiest thing to
take off because you don't want it to
come off that easy if it was easy to
come off you put things inside of it it
might fall off on accident this is very
secure so that is the first style pack
here let's move on to other accessories
or other style packs that they have and
sort of customize it to our liking so
this could be used let's say as your
headphone case reason being if you have
let's say airpods max which don't fold
up and you don't want to carry around
the sort of case that apple has with it
but you want protection you can put it
in something like this it's got a carbon
fiber design on the outside of it very
cool also it has those velcro
tabs here so you can actually undo that
if you like it is padded inside as well
so this will protect your electronic
items or your headphones because airpod
max you don't want to scratch them
they're very beautiful and there you go
and then you can attach this
to the bag
either on the top or the bottom so i put
onto the bottom area
all locked there
your headphones are now attached to your
backpack then if i want to style it up a
little bit more i have these other
pouches here and i can lock those in
place
and you've got your design then if i
want to just complete the look and have
the pouches on the side i can do that as
well smartphone gloves whatever you want
to take to the gym plus your clothing
inside you are covered
all right thanks zacky the nice thing is
with this water bottle uh design
actually this locks here you just
tighten the straps
it's secure
and there we go
water bottle is in there it's secure
it's not coming out
zacky come be my model again put it on
and zach is now
ready for the gym look at he's jumping
around nothing's coming out
sorry this
wasn't looking for the butt shake zaki
but okay shank shake shake shake shake
yeah
thanks zacky so now
what about another style well we
actually have more products here let's
just take this off real quick
this carbon fiber one is a little bit
tricky because it's hard
remove those and now we move on to this
other pouch here which is more of a
how do i say this i guess you could put
some
what did you put in this exactly maybe a
tablet has a zipper on this ykk zipper
as well actually just locked onto that
see how quick this magnet thing is
quite stylo quite hipsters and then
again we can put our pouches on the side
if we want to do that
and we have a whole new look to this
but what about the inside my shoe
because i did mention about the fidlock
system inside let me show you what that
is about someone for like for zacky who
might want to store his toothbrush and
his toiletries in his bag but doesn't
want to wrap them in where his socks and
his shoes are at well there's actually
this pouch
now this pouch is uh you call this a
little bit of a toiletry bag or you can
use it for cables or whatever you want
to use it for
a lens
a lens and it also has dividers inside
as well so you can divide it velcro
dividers
but
it's felt inside feel nice this is zack
you feel how nice this is
fancy very very fancy but let's say we
want to take this
sony alpha lens here
pop it inside
so if you want to attach this to the
inside of your bag use the fidlock
system so
one lock here and this hook goes through
the loop on the bag to keep it in place
now what this does is with the weight
that's in this pouch it keeps it
suspended
so if i'm shaking this up and down
nothing's happening
right so if you're going to keep let's
say
you know a camera lens in this or
something delicate you don't have to
worry about this banging or falling out
because it's suspended based on the
weight and the fidlock system inside of
it and the great thing about this is is
that with the fidlocks here and this
hook system the weight is keeping it all
into place but i'm also hearing that
there's gonna be future attachments that
they're gonna be making for this bag
that will utilize this system inside so
perhaps i'm hearing something with
cameras that would be very cool so you
can actually have a camera system inside
and it's suspended so even if you drop
your bag hypothetically
nothing's going to hit the bottom of it
because it's suspended inside of the bag
thanks to the fitlock system and the
hook we also have this other pouch here
that we can use as well so if you want
to you know take this piece off
use this
you can do that as well so let's say you
want to put this on the top
then you want to use this piece of the
bottom
you now have a completely
different looking bag
for whatever you need but that's the
cool thing about this orion backpack is
that it can be any bag you wanted to be
rather some bag company dictating to you
what bag you should be carrying you can
make it your own now i want to show you
also the something that's very
interesting with this and this is the
laptop sleeve
now this is a separate device that does
not attach the bag
but it's also nice to have but let's say
you don't want to carry a backpack one
day let's say you just want to carry
this and maybe a pouch or two well you
can actually do that this can be your
bag system so zacky has been kind enough
to drop me over this macbook pro we'll
put it inside this is a 13 inch and it
fits in beautifully actually i think a
16 inch can fit into this there's plenty
of room you can also put a tablet inside
there if you want ipad pro and if you
notice it has its own fidlock system on
this so
theoretically i could take
these two
and i could actually put it on the side
so now
my laptop sleeve actually has extra
pouches for my cable management system
or accessories or whatever it is
and then i also have this
pouch inside here to store more things
so now you don't you just bring this
along has a handle
and
yeah you're good to go
[Music]
versus carrying a large backpack if you
want to stay like say nice and light and
you know minimal
you're covered in that regard
so there's a lot of variations that you
can do with this and also we've got this
keychain
a strap fidlock system and also we have
a sunglass pouch as well so if you want
to utilize these things you can all with
the fidlock lock on each on the back of
them so
this is the nice thing about this whole
design system from 227design.com is as i
mentioned before it can be anything you
want it to be there's all these
accessories you can get for it and
they're gonna keep coming out with more
style packs as they go along based on
you know customer feedback and use cases
like what i'm hearing from them right
now is that a camera system will be
coming out in the near future uh this is
something near and dear to me because i
love carrying cameras with me in camera
gear and i love this backpack for what
it is but i'm looking for something that
i can put inside so i can put a few
lenses or a couple camera bodies and i'm
hearing that's going to be coming out
within the next couple months of the
time we're shooting this video so that
will be exciting to see but uh just for
my you know day-to-day usage over the
past couple weeks wearing this i really
like it um it's comfortable it's durable
it's weather resistant i love the fact
that it stands up on its own i don't
worry about that and i can completely
customize it to be how i wanted to be
for the day uh which is nice this is the
227design.com orion backpack modular
system with all the style packs
and zacky what do you think dude if
batman needed a bag
this is it man
yeah the utility pouch
but he can't wear a backpack you wanna
know why why he wears a cape
right
but i know what you're saying yes i know
what you're saying it's like a utility
belt but in a backpack yeah in a
nutshell this is a definitely a bag
worth checking out so check out this uh
website 227design.com
there's some early bird pricing i don't
know if that's still applicable or not
because that was for the kickstarter
campaign but even at its normal pricing
there is a lot to unpack pun intended in
this backpack for the price point it's
durable lightweight
robust and i love these style packs and
i can't wait to see what else they come
up with so anyway those are my thoughts
on the backpack let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below
are you looking to pick this up is this
something that you've been interested in
any questions you have on it let us know
we'll try to answer them for you so with
that guys take care stay safe and we'll
chat to you soon bye
you